oh we can use the method of induction
right for something like this even
though it's like don't really know all
that much about this but we can see how
it works and how it pans out so let's
give the first one to go shall we
this one approve that's the N minus one
is divisible by X minus one now I'm just
going to pause there for a second okay
um this is interesting because if I just
stop there you could prove that you can
prove that okay how did you prove it
you don't need induction to prove that
come on think about it you could do it
via there's a simple way there's a
simpler way isn't there all of these
things right excellent this so you X
minus one x squared minus one X cube
minus one and so on right very very
predictable right how would you prove
that something is divisible by X minus
one you know a theorem for this you know
the fact that you've had this years ago
right what does the fact that theorem
say if you take the zero that
corresponds to this which is one right
if you stick one into this and you get
zero you get a factor haha there it is
okay I suppose if I have rewritten it
and said prove that X minus 1 is a
factor all xcms why you would have
recognized a little easier but factors
divisibility that the same thing just to
finish okay ah but then they throw a
spanner in the works they say yeah we
get that okay take your early option and
they say get lost do it some other way
okay which we can so how do we do it
what do we want we want on all positive
integers okay so you tell me what's the
first step test
okay so you stick it in you get X to the
1 minus 1 well I'm not going to go
division on it because I think it's
divisible by X minus 1 just going to go
with it ok true for the first allowable
no I can go ask you now what should I
assume because just like the arm the
divisible proofs with numbers right they
have it I haven't given you a straight
equation right so what could you write
I'm assuming it's true for this value N
equals K where K follows the same rules
that n does okay any suggestions what
would it mean if this were divisible by
this I'll start with having K in there
right X to the K minus sorry minus 1
what statement can I make about this
mathematically that would be equivalent
to this what should it be equal to
it should be X minus 1 multiplied by
some other polynomial who knows what it
is we cares what it is right if there's
a polynomial over there okay that's a
factor which means it's the visible
okay that's divisible I suppose I should
say where P is a polynomial just in
cases and videos okay no one okay I want
proof right I'm gonna prove it for the
next case an equals k plus 1 what does
it look like X to the k plus 1 minus 1 I
still want that to be a factor there
will be something else who knows but
something else right now what can I do
to this thing even though it's all X's
it is remarkably similar to what you've
been doing with numbers right I'll start
with the left hand side again it's X to
the k plus 1 minus 1 yes
ok now I need to do some simplifying
here but I'm not simplifying blindly in
any direction right in fact if I was
just thinking about simplifying looks
pretty simple to me
right I don't have to do anything to it
but I want to do it something to it for
what reason what am i trying to work
toward I need to use this don't I I need
to bring it into place somehow okay so
any suggestions should I do
hmm the last time I had a Ford here
didn't I okay and I said well I've got
four to the campus one but I want a four
to the K right I know it looks different
but it's not X is something I'm not like
for whatever it is I just know it's
about one okay I can do exactly the same
thing I index laws tell us that that is
equal to x times X to the K that's one
okay
am i in position to use my assumption
yeah pretty close though our time pretty
close okay
I don't want X of those I just want one
okay so let me just put one over here
for saving there's one of those okay so
if I took out one how many will be left
over the X minus one in our case before
it was three wasn't it X minus one oh
that's convenient right that's how many
X the case I have left and I'm adding
that now I can use my assumption that's
X minus 1 and what did I say that was
equal to X minus 1 times some other
polynomial okay you can see I've done
the hard work now haven't I
okay take you sorry by assumption okay
so I take my factor out and now you can
see what Q is right or at least you can
see what it is in terms of P there you
go there is okay that is cute and you're
fine from there okay make your
explanation and you're finished so this
is where you look at this how many
numbers are on the board
well there's some ones and that's about
it so your mind starts to spin out a
little bit when you like so many letters
okay but don't don't be too afraid
just think about in terms of if we did
it with numbers and it was no trouble so
you can do without a rock